[Música]
buenas tardes
soy venezolano
pero también soy costarricense porque
costarricense no es necesariamente el
que nace costarricense al igual que don
jacques sagot tengo mis dos dieces allá
arriba a mi esposa milagro en mi hija
vanessa son mis dos dieces que trae
ahora y yo somos costarricenses porque
amamos costa rica gracias
gracias por los aplausos yo tengo un
amigo que se llama ricardo bulnes
riccardo dice si a mí me aplauden antes
de iniciar la charla es un acto de fe
tenemos fe de que vaya a decir algo
porque no sabemos de qué hablar y no lo
conocemos
si me aplauden en la mitad es un acto de
esperanza
tenemos esperanza de que cambie porque
no ha dicho nada
si me aplauden al final es un acto de
caridad
vamos a aplaudirle para que se vea
tranquilo mi esposa siempre aplaude las
tres no importa él siempre me aplaude
ustedes comenzaron con el acto de fe
muchas gracias muchas gracias
por favor de pie rapidito joint anís
olmo lo que ponemos a trabajar a la
gente que un momentito rápido van a
saludar en cinco segundos a la persona
que tienes a tu lado y como si fuera una
persona que no es importante para ti es
más está buscando alguien más importante
no es importante para ti no es no es o
que ya dejen la eco crecía ya vaya va
ahora ahora si vas a saludar al que
tienes a tu alrededor como si fuera una
persona que tienes años que no ves que
la quieren muchísimo salud ese sabroso
así eso también también es salud a la
eso ya ya ya ya ya tome asiento tome
asiento y tome asiento
tomen asiento tomen asiento okay
rápidamente dos actividades dos
actividades la primera cual tuvo más
energía
la segunda verdad de eso vamos a hablar
hoy el camino a la excelencia qué es lo
que hace que ese engranaje se mueva que
esa grasa mueva ese engranaje para que
ese camino sea más fácil sea más ligero
sea menos pesado como lo quieras decir
sea
esa grasa es la felicidad y eso fue lo
que ustedes expresaron con esa energía
la felicidad hablemos empecemos por
costa a costa rica es un país bello
adornado por la selva y el coral pero
saben que tiene problemas no es perfecto
tiene problemas de tráfico tiene
problemas de puertos aeropuertos bueno
le voy a decir algo felicito a la gente
del aeropuerto la gente de aeris que
anda por ahí han hecho un trabajo
fantástico con el aeropuerto pero si
tienen problema con las vías tiene
problemas pero saben que yo prefiero eso
a un país sin democracia yo prefiero eso
a un país sin salud
yo prefiero eso a un país sin educación
y saben que costa rica es un bello país
y está bien calificado costa rica es el
primer país para los que no sabían de
democracia de latinoamérica es el primer
país en desarrollo social de
latinoamérica es el primer país verde de
latinoamérica y uno de los mejores del
mundo con todo lo que podamos decir
costa rica es el primer país en libertad
de prensa de latinoamérica costa rica
según el happy planet index es el país
más feliz del mundo agua potable salud
educación pib y un montón de desarrollo
social etcétera pero dice ahí en el
periódico hace dos semanas salió que
éramos 12 pero eso es otra encuesta yo
tomé la del api planner index y se acabó
ok es el país más feliz del mundo pero
porque es el país más feliz del mundo
porque es un país que está orientado
hacia la sostenibilidad
-juan este el don carlos alvarado
hablaron de esto de la sostenibilidad
crear riqueza ganar dinero pero en
armonía con la sociedad y el medio
ambiente
costa rica es un país bien calificado
porque hay una cultura empresarial hay
una cultura de comunidad
que muchos jóvenes de costa rica y del
mundo no saben cómo han tardado como
como han pasado del año 1869 cuando
declararon la educación obligatoria y
gratuita pero este cuando eliminaron el
ejército y una cantidad de parámetros
que se fueron generando que no no fue
gratis costa rica sus empresas y cuando
vamos a las empresas ahora son empresas
que tienen cultura y esa cultura la
cultura que es son los hábitos
comportamientos temores costumbres y los
valores ojos valores valores todo
aquello a lo que damos un significado
que para nosotros es valioso y si nos
rodeamos de valores que apreciemos
seremos personas de éxito o empresas de
excelencia
si quieres profundamente a tus hijos
valora la paternidad si te educas
constantemente valoras la educación si
mantiene saciado lo que te rodea valorar
limpieza valor ahora cuando tú te rodeas
de valores y puedes que lo que tienes
que hacer
necesitas sacrificio para poderlos
modelar y el sacrificio se logra con
voluntad y la voluntad se logra cuando
trabajas con amor pero un amor de eros y
de feel y amor de ágape pero cuando
tienes esa pasión ese deseo ardiente que
puedes tienes la voluntad para
sacrificarse y modelar por este
compromiso respeto excelencia pasión
entidad y alegría y saben que ahí está
la base todos ustedes que están aquí son
un milagro un milagro de dios somos un
milagro sabes cuántas personas se
necesitaron para que tú estuvieras aquí
hoy bueno se lo voy a decir tu papá y tu
mamá se tuvieron que unir tu abuelo y tu
abuela por parte de padre y madre ese
número está calculado más o menos 34
millones de personas tuvieron reunirse
en algún lugar del planeta y en algún
algún momento del tiempo para que tú
nacieras o sea en la probabilidad es más
tu papá tuvo que generar 200 millones de
espermatozoides y tú fuiste que fecunda
este
la probabilidad 1 sobre 34 1 sobre 200
millones es infinitesimalmente o sea
ustedes son un milagro si al haber
nacido tienen que ser agradecidos porque
estamos vivos porque estamos aquí
decimos aplauso porque eso verdad que es
un milagro
ahora bien
y se los voy a decir entender esta
dimensión es entender que la vida ya la
vida no es ayer la vida no es mañana la
vida es hoy y vive el presente porque en
esa estación pasará el resto de tu vida
eso lo decía facundo cabral la vida es
ya si tuviera que anunciar a un artista
dirías del giat sagot lo verás mañana o
pasado mañana si no lo veo y lo que es
mañana o si no lo ves en otro u otra
oportunidad si tuvieras que presentar la
vida como la presentaría la vida
única presentación porque saben una cosa
vamos a pasar por aquí una sola vez
y créanme ahora ahora hablamos que costa
rica tiene otro indicador tiene uno de
los plus son que la gente pasa de los
100 años es más promedio de costa rica
pasar a los 80 pero en el mundo el
promedio de 70 años y 70 años son 25 mil
550 días es más si dura 100 años son 36
mil 500 días una vez en una charla un
señor se levantó así como de unos 70
años y preguntó ajá dígame el señor esté
ahí están incluidos los feriados incluya
los si quieres pero
y a veces no entendemos que la vida pasa
muy rápido y perdemos el tiempo y no
somos felices porque lo mejor de la vida
te tocó a ti el mejor padre te tocó a ti
la mejor madre el mejor hermano la mejor
empresa la mejor esposa le tocó a ti y
el esposo también porque de 20 pero el
que mi papá es un borracho te dio la
vida es el mejor de quién es el mejor
cuerpo el tuyo que te dio la vida lo
mejor de la vida te tocó a ti y no hay
día feo la gente se queja hay que hacer
calor te gusta la papaya te gusta el
mango te gusta el banano eso crece en el
calor se ha agradecido hay que este día
está feo no señora está lloviendo
no está ahí está feo no está bien señora
está bien porque cuando tú está feo por
dentro todo lo ve feo porque pan duro no
es pan duro duro es no tener pan el
problema no es el trabajo el problema es
pasar trabajo el problema no es la
pareja el problema de estar solo
en ese pan está duro mojarlo café con
leche
no tengo café con leche no tengo leche
me hallo en agua no tengo agua se acabó
mojado con la saliva porque para eso se
hizo la saliva para mojar los alimentos
pan duro no es pan duro sea agradecido
se feliz con lo que tienes vive tu
realidad y se lo voy a decir las cosas
más importantes de la vida son gratis
las cosas más importantes de la vida
cuánto cuesta un carro caro
bmw mercedes 80 mil dólares mis piernas
son gratis y a veces nos olvidamos de
esa dimensión señores cuánto cuesta un
trasplante de glándulas salivales
se lo voy a decir tú pones aquí mil
millones de dólares y escupes aquí tiene
más valor para la vida
es escupitajo que está ahí que los mil
millones porque no existe no existe
trasplante hablando las salivales como y
sin saliva entonces tú haces decir
dios mío gracias por mi saliva porque no
estás consciente de lo importante de la
salida cómo vas a comer sin saliva cómo
vas a dormir en más muchachas cómo van a
besar en seco no va no puede empezar si
de eso se trata verá las cosas más
importantes señor es el que tiene amigos
tiene amor el que tiene escoltas tiene
miedo
y a veces nos olvidamos que las cosas
más sencillas son las más importantes
porque confundimos tranquila
tranquilidad con comodidad
si ponemos aquí 1492 descubrió
centroamérica y ponemos aquí 2019 en
tecnología bueno hoy hablamos de
tecnologías por todas hacemos así pero
en valores vamos así porque estamos
cambiando tranquilidad para cómo eran
las cámaras nuestro abuelo catre hamaca
esterilla hoy las camas es ortopédicos
invierto pédico es más los nombres son
sweetdreams paradise confort
y sufre y sufre de insomnio y sufre
insomnio
es más yo tengo un amigo que tiene una
cama 4x4 y está divorciados y porque tú
tienes esa cama
está de vuelta bueno mente para el
parque
los baños como eran los baños los baños
eran letrinas las letrinas quedaban a 40
metros fuera de la casa por obra pública
no se podía tener adentro es más mi
abuelo donde va decía la abuela voy al
baño que te vaya bien era un viaje se
despedía en radio hoy tenemos hoy
tenemos una taza un inodoro a tres
metros de nuestras posibilidades y
sufrimos estreñimiento señores para
dormir lo que se necesita es estar
cansado y a veces confundimos eso la
comodidad no es mucha comodidad a tus
hijos 15 que aprecien la tranquilidad y
ahí viene la base la felicidad es el
arte de combinar el sí con él no es
tristeza y esa alegría es vivir tu duelo
y se lo voy a decir de esta manera
el dolor cuídate no te cuides del dolor
cuídate del sufrimiento el dolor duele
pero no hunde cuando el dolor paz en
tiempo se convierte en sufrimiento que
pasa señora por qué llora mi pareja me
dejó caramba porque hace cuánto hace 20
años
pero que acs otra vez no es que los
hombres son son un desastre no señora si
son ahora son peores
y se lo voy a decir el que sufre o día
todo el que sufre y el que no ríe no ama
porque la alegría es el brillo del amor
y es tristeza y alegría es vivir la
realidad de lo que tienes es ser
agradecido y vivir tu realidad y la
felicidad es una decisión el que no ríe
no ama ay pero mi esposo no ríe no te
ama pero el riel los domingos en la
tarde te llama el domingo en la tarde
pero ríe poquito te llama poquito
señor el buen humor mantener a veces la
gente inteligente es la más seria porque
así dice el que es más serio es más
inteligente al que no ama porque los
intelectuales los intelectuales los
intelectuales todo esto no se dan cuenta
que tenemos más una universidad y
estamos peor los intelectuales buscan
las ideas los inteligentes buscan la
vida ustedes quieren seguir a alguien
sigan a los animales el perro huele lo
que come y si no le gusta no se lo come
se busca el agua una cucaracha viene por
aquí tú vas a matar la cucaracha no se
regrese hasta que no ella huye se va se
pierde
se pierde la cucaracha busca la vida
nosotros no nosotros a un camping y
guerra por aquí sale por ella porque
vivimos las ideas no nos están matando
muchas veces no somos inteligentes
muchas veces y se lo voy a decir las
recetas de la felicidad ser agradecido
ya se los dije
y tomar lo bueno desechar lo malo
y fuerza de voluntad dicen que los
edificios más fuertes los más duros son
los que se rompen más rápidos y los más
flexibles son los que se mantienen los
terremotos humor buen humor
se ha utilizando la presentación de mi
amigo héctor a ya que me encantó tu
presentación este tu sabes mi concepto
de fe héctor yo salgo de mi casa y me
pongo en manos de dios pero si erro mi
casa viste
yo la cierro claro hay que ser precavido
porque eso de que a mí no me ha pasado
no no yo soy venezolano y yo sí sé qué
pasa si pasa si pasa fe perdón sacarse
adentro todos los paradigmas poder de
elección de elegir ser feliz ahora el
caballo se hizo para correr hasta el
cansancio
dicen que el avestruz corre más rápido
pero qué rapero no corre está el
cansancio el río para llegar al mar el
águila para volar para volar bajo el sol
del mediodía la montaña para ser alta
el sapo para ser feo
yapo feo verdad y deprimido de ese más
feo también pero se hizo el hombre para
que se hizo el hombre se hizo para ser
feliz y el hombre que no se hizo para
ser feliz se hizo para destruir y
créanme hay que decidir ser feliz y ahí
está la excelencia personas de
excelencia personas felices personas que
viven en su duelo pero que vive en su
realidad son comunidades felices son
empresas felices son empresas con climas
laborales con gente identificada y
comprometida y eso se traduce en un país
feliz por ejemplo costa rica
para mi felicidad
es despertar en a las cuatro de la
mañana viéndome acostado tarde solo para
dar una vuelta a la cama de mi hijo solo
para verlo dormir
para mi felicidad es un cálido hogar una
calidad mesa un té caliente al desayuno
la dulce melodía de una canción para
inspirar el corazón para mi felicidad es
disfrutar del sol del frío de la lluvia
es dar afecto a los demás pero ante todo
felicidad es estar lleno de valores
valores que apreciemos por eso valora tu
hijo a tu esposa a tu familia a tu
empresa tu país valora te a ti mismo que
es la base de la sociedad la familia y
créanme el ave canta aunque la rama
cruja porque ella sabe lo que son sus
alas no importa que el vendaval nos
azote y que los problemas nos agobien
ustedes sabemos de lo que somos capaces
vive tu realidad
sé feliz decide ser feliz si decide lo y
saben que no se pongan serios sonrían
está bien costa rica
muchas gracias
[Aplausos]
[Música]